hi thanks thanks everyone so just maybe
yeah I was kind of already said espera
my name is Liam Kerwin so I'm currently
a QB the large insurance company we do
corporate insurance of b2b and the data
science team does a lot of different
things the two big categories of those
are risk models and fraud models that
can be things from you know motor fleets
to professional indemnity for lawyers to
wind farms international shipping a lot
lots of different things to now to
figure out how risky they are and lost
the data is categorical and and lots of
it is it's pretty messy as long as data
sets that were 20 years ago were just a
set of Excel files and sometimes today
are still like until quite recently were
on Excel so there's lots lots of
experience doing doing this kind of
thing and the talk yes okay in case it
wasn't totally clear
katkat ashore from categorical variables
so does it anything that's not a number
often in Python and programming
languages these are some string
basically that you have in your data a
lot of different strategies for dealing
with them so today is an intro ish level
talk about different strategies for
dealing with them so I'm going to assume
in a basic familiarity familiarity or
with Python and and scikit-learn and
things like that but not too too much
else the context I'm going to be talking
about it's in a standard IEEE standard
supervised learning so just not talking
about unsupervised learning and and not
at all about you know neural networks
and other things it's gonna to to
broader topic otherwise and there will
be what I hope is a tasteful number of
cactus was struggling over right the way
balance was but we'll see there we go
so there's basically three sections
first several different coding
strategies you know what they are pros
and cons to a little bit a few things to
think about general strategy like when
you have categorical variables in your
data
what should you think about doing I've
been what order of how should you
approach it and three I'm going to talk
specifically about three packages so
excuse let GBM and cap gustar come far
and away the most popular
graeme boosted decision tree packages
and are super common you know real world
cattle everywhere and they deal with a
categorical variables very different
ways in some ways it's one of the key
differences between them so may be
interesting to dive into that just a
little bit more yes alright it's so just
quick definition before we start to
maybe which you call families of
categorical data so you can have ordered
ordered data where there's some kind of
low to high thing so or maybe this this
one and I agree neutral disagree is high
below it could be a bit of variation
within there here there can be no stuff
that is you know maybe the levels are
quite even you know maybe this you could
think of representing it as 1 0 minus 1
and that would be pretty fair other
times you can have ordered categories
where the gaps between them might be
quite big
so it might not be totally totally fair
to just you know assume some numbers and
probably the more common almost
certainly more common kind of
categorical variables is unordered you
know you have a bunch of categories in
no particular obvious order yeah ok so
section one cat encodings all right so
first off I have they're like two
standards I could learn things so
labeling courting encoding is also
called ordinal and code
various other things I think one thing
about this area it's that's toughest
there's a lot of different names for the
same kind of idea but this is basically
where you would just assign each level
of the category an integer and do
nothing else so it's really simple you
know it's come it's just a one-to-one
mapping the major big problem is this
might imply an ordered relationship
depending on the modeling context and
that's you know if the variable is
ordered maybe that's okay
if it's unordered then it's almost
certainly not a good thing to do
so a simplest thing to do but but not I
think very uncommon ly the the right
thing to do one caught and one hot
encoding is perhaps like the classic
default thing to do with categorical
variables so same same list of
categories will transform into something
that has three columns one row for each
observation and we have one column for
fuzzy a one for smooths and one for soft
and if it's one if it's the observation
has that category and it's zero if it's
not and so this is this is yeah this is
one hot encoder ends I could learn it's
perhaps like the standard thing to do
for many algorithms and the right
Committee for many algorithms but the
main downsides just kind of there's a
bit of a tutu and one you know two sides
of the same coin and I think if you have
a lot of levels which is quite common a
real world real world data you'll end up
with a huge number of columns in your
ear resulting matrix
you know I imagine like ten thousand
hundred thousand depending on your data
set and it's gonna have two impacts
similar different one is you know it's
just gonna create use up a lot of memory
and so if you're if your data isn't
trivially small you might run into
performance impacts
you know maybe you need to find a bigger
machine or it just takes forever to fit
your models also for a lot of algorithms
this is going to start impacting the
quality of the solution that the
algorithm find it's just kind of too
many choices - to cope with well I'll
talk about that a little bit more later
so that's a strategy to count encoding
I'm sort of you know just like us and
this I think in my mind like slightly
more reasonable version of label
encoding you still get a nice kind of
one-to-one mapping you know like the the
output is the same size as the input so
you don't have the explosion you'll get
with one heart but instead of replacing
it just assigning a string to an integer
you replace it with the count of the
number of times this level showed up in
the the training data so so here we have
a fuzzy and soft you show up once smooth
shows up twice so it gets two and I
think so it's kind of similar to label
encoding it's I think a little bit
better in general because it's plausibly
useful you know separating you know
arraign arranging them in order of small
to big on a number line is it's probably
more useful than a random ordering and
you can think of an algorithm like a
tree based model easily using that to
create another category like anything
below ten examples is just group
together in the same or they even
treated together so if you know for
various constraints in a real world
problem if I had to do something like
label encoding I would probably do that
instead and there was a history of this
being used quite successfully on Kaggle
I think which is our only reason I want
to throw it in is doing the Kami coding
in to actually boost or something was
very uh put a popular strategy for for a
while before some of the linear pack
just came out okay so next was targeting
coding it's kind of the most basic
version of targeting coding just replace
each group with the mean of the target
variable within that group so one of
those an example data here so we have a
four row so there's there's only one
example of fuzzy so it gets three
there's two examples of smooth four or
five so you just transform the gee
column into they mean within the groups
so it's something that can work really
well and it comes for obvious reasons if
if you're trying to predict a target the
Y variable then like directly encoding
that is it's quite an intuitively nice
thing to do but it can run you into
problems very quickly as you can think
of it's like directly leaky like you
know in one basic concept and machine
learning is not letting your your target
leak somehow into your data set now this
very direct example of that you know
since this is this the value in each row
is directly used in the calculation of
the group mean so I'll create a feature
that your model thinks is amazing and
fits two very strongly but it's just
useless when it you go to unseen data so
there this is kind of like this I think
this is not generally used in practice
but it's the simplest simplest example
and there's a couple variations on it
that will move on to I think one one
classic thing you see and as though
people are starting out machine learning
is to calculate these means before
splitting the data into training and
holdout sets which will just yeah you
know shoot yourself in the foot for
doing any kind of valid
measurement of the performance of your
model so instead of target coding what
can we do so leave one out it's kind of
a next next step so it's similar
so you're calculating group means
basically but you leave each row itself
out from the calculation so again tiny
data sets a little bit let's reveal but
you have this in this row value for
fuzzy is three and four the leave one
out value you just do the average of the
rest all other examples of fuzzy so in
case there's one so it says for for
smooth you can see that a little more
operation so this the value of six is
the average of five six seven and
similar for the others so it's better
you're kind of not directly leaking the
target into each observation but in
practice especially with machine
learning models that are quite flexible
you still end up overfitting and there's
basically there's two reasons here one
one is that for each group and I think
from a statistics point of view if you
you're in your data set you have a kind
of a random sample of the of each
category smooth you know you might have
a sample that's where the sample mean is
above or below the true mean as a group
not just enough individually so you know
if in your data set you happen to have a
group of smooth ones where it's just
over does the sample mean is above the
the true underlying mean for that group
then you're still gonna tend to over fit
and I think more more subtly especially
when you have complex models you can
actually kind of still figure out what
what the value is like if you notice for
for smooth we have four five six seven
so increasing values
and then end up with decreasing values
of the leave one out encoding so like in
general you know the higher the value of
the target for a particular row the
lower the value of the leave one out
maybe so you know it'll be a noisy
signal for a machine learning model but
it can probably just pick out the
reverse of it and so this helps a bit
compared to target encoding it's just
sort of certainly better than nothing
but in practice you still find I've
never found that it and solve the
overfitting problem oh here I have a
link to an implementation of this or
what have no internet and on the Wi-Fi
so I'll try to get onto it and we'll see
I'll just move on in the meantime
okay after leave one out so it's more
common to some kind of smooth hard
encoding so basically the Zed is your
the final variable that you come up with
and you have some weight between the
group mean and and the global means so
the group mean is area you're in group
so within within smooth for example
what's this mean versus the global mean
what's the mean of all of the Y
variables and some some waiting between
those and you generally set it up it's
not exactly this formula that's that's
used in different cases but it's this
basic idea and it's generally W wool
will go up for for larger groups so for
you know a quite small group maybe you'd
have W is this is ten percent and my
subs ninety percent and so it's it's
quite close to the global mean and then
as the size of the group increases you
put more and more weight on the group
mean and it's gonna make its intuitive
sense because the smaller the sample the
the noise your that sample is going to
be and I thought lest you can trust that
that group mean and let me just see if
I've connected yes okay so there's a
category encoders library its psychic
contribs related to but not part of the
socket learn and there's a bunch of what
the things I'm talking about plus some
others implemented as transformers that
you can plug into scikit-learn pipelines
so there's a target encoder for does it
leave one out go there and there's lots
of others to to look at if you're
interested I have I'm trying to add
trying to hit the main ones now so
one thing that I'm going to briefly
mention but not really talked about in
detail is embeddings so if any of you
are familiar with NLP you'll be familiar
with these so word Tyvek was the classic
or original version of this so I'm not
moving not the original version but kind
of the thing that repopulated it
recently basically ideas you can map
words to some like 100 dimensional 500
dimensional vector space and you can
build it in a way that similar words are
grouped together so no cat and bomb cat
and lion and would be close together and
far away from something like truck or
skyscraper so if you have the right data
this this can be a very powerful
approach I'm not gonna cover those in
details so that the small something
that's looking to it if it makes sense I
think that what the one thing I will say
is that there are lots of pre-trained
vectors available so you can go out
there's a set of these
it's called glove which are very very
well known and totally public and so you
if you have some data that's like
keywords and you want to cannot figure
out which keywords are close to each
other you can just download a
pre-trained
set of these that were built on I know
all of Wikipedia or something like that
and just stick them in and there's been
a couple models at QB where this has
been just off the shelf
a really really good approach with
without too much work ok so that's those
are all the basic encoding types next
section strategy so this is man like
what what kinds of things do you want do
you want to think about when you get a
data set you have categorical variables
in it
what kind of thing you should think
about first thing always its no ever
ever present boring but very important
cleaning it up and you know so some of
this is just wrangling stuff in pandas
as per usual there's a few packages that
I've never used multiple times and I've
have found helpful
so first is fuzzy wuzzy which is
basically fuzzy string similarity so if
you have two strings that are close but
but not exactly the same you can get a
score from zero to honor and how similar
are these and so it's kind of useful if
you're combining two sources or you want
to group some things together there's a
few different ratios Rex Pi is a little
bit I think less known and it's Mike
mileage is varied with it but it was at
least one case where it was very helpful
so one do a little demo of it I actually
think I might have it okay so this is
Rick's PI it's a it's a Python package
that you can install this is a website
which just has a live demo of it and so
I hope everyone can see this basically
what we have here is under a set of this
is something that could be IDs you know
they all follow a similar pattern but I
think it was numeric but they're they're
kind of each of them are different so
Rex PI will try to automatically
discover regular expressions that
capture that and then you can use to to
match things against it and so it's you
know it's there's no one like
correctness guarantees or even
guarantees that will find a good
solution but I found it has worked in a
fairly well and what's what's helpful is
that if you have something that's
totally unrelated so
yeah somebody that's very different
it'll return two separate results I mean
like how many ever you know there's some
things you can configure but and
obviously sort out what's the minimal
set of reg axes that will take to
describe this data and so if you have
different kinds of II's or different you
know things that are like similar but
different in a way that can be picked up
by a regular expression this might give
you a really handy summary of what those
are and then you can never use the
regular expressions to create some
aggregated groups your data that's been
quite for me a couple different times
dirty cat it is another Python package
just a couple examples there and one
thing I've got the most useful thing I
found is a similarity encoder which is
in a kind of similar like a word
embedding kind of way if you feed it a
bunch of text it'll try to group similar
ones together and give them similarity
scores so you know again scikit-learn
compliant you can plug it into to a
pipeline and you can get things it's
like this so this is just this is an
example straight from the Theodore T cat
documentation where you know we've fed
in some job titles and this is kind of a
multi-dimensional no scaling of the of
the resulting similarities that the
encoder has come up with and which is
like the strings that are similar having
been grouped together and so this is
Donal just a pure like a bass string
similarity kind of way but if you do
have do you know where there's small
variations it might be a quick and easy
way to
to group those into aggregate categories
so those things are all about like
cleaning the data set that you have I'd
say be often from a most important thing
to do is to think outside your data set
a little bit so there is there's some
external data you can get that can
explain how these groups are related I
think it's you know you can easy to get
into a kind of cackle style mindset
where you're like okay this is my data
and I will build my model but there's so
much abuse 'fl public external data out
there that you can almost certainly do
better than that so I just have kind of
a few random examples on the top of my
head
geographic areas there's a lot of
obvious ones you know if you have
something like countries the the stream
country name your your models can have
no idea which countries are beside each
other if you plug in latitudes longer do
something you can get that maybe
elevation is important maybe population
density is important that's kind of what
what numbers can you relevant numbers
can you find that will tell your model
which which of these categories are
close to each other for why you might
look at alcohol or sugar levels what's
in the wine some online ratings grape
from from a website if you're working on
a website and you have you know user
sessions from different browsers Firefox
Chrome my different versions of each you
know maybe you maybe just plug those in
or maybe there's something you know
maybe the release date of the browser
will tell you something about the kind
of user that you're interacting with so
I think thinking about that thing kind
of thing is quite important also kind of
similar to where we are looking at
before can you roll small groups up into
larger ones if you have you know post
code data maybe you need regions or
maybe you need countries which will be
easier for your algorithm to always
and yes so like I was saying before if
you have keyword type data can you use
some off-the-shelf embeddings I think
this is no this is one side of my talk
but this is often if you if you can get
this right this you know sometimes
changing things about your algorithm
will give you 10% or 15% improvement but
finding a really good new external data
source can be an order of magnitude
difference so it's definitely important
to remember what encoding should I use
if you have few like if it's 4 or less
just definitely one hot encoded you know
and you could maybe scale that up as the
data set size increases that kind of
depends on you know how how balanced
your target is you know if you have very
imbalanced data now your say a QB when
we're predicting fraud maybe now 2% 2%
of claims of some sort of fraud
associated with them now your your data
sets effectively not as big as one with
more balanced classes but yeah as it
goes where's the smaller and one haunt
coding has a simple thing and it will
work well the more categories you go as
who you want to believe more and more
towards the targeting coding approaches
and and some of the stuff that we're
going to talk about the gradient
boosting libraries thing to think about
is do you care about interactions so an
interaction between some something an
observation being a certain group and
how it interacts with another variable
so for example I know maybe thinking
about browsers is a lot it's the last
example maybe your browser's you're
looking at conversion weights on your
website
maybe Firefox and Chrome have about the
same average conversion but they have a
very different interaction with some
other thing in your data sets if you
target in code at and just get a new
column you're going to
lose the information that those two
groups are different they're kind of
they're gonna get the same or similar
target encoding score and your models
Canada is substantially lose its ability
to figure out interactions so those are
important be be cautious of that and
also think about interpretability and
maintainability you know a nice thing
about one Haughton coding is it's very
interpretable you have a different
column for each one if you do something
like counting coding it's gonna be a lot
harder to explain to other people how
it's working or show the precise effect
of something being in this category so I
think those are those are the big things
I would think about these decisions so
feature importance for categories I
think this is like all scikit-learn
estimators and other packages will have
their inbuilt feature importance to you
about your model these are often quite
inconsistent and this one's misleading
for categorical variables especially
especially tree based models where
sometimes the feature importance is
based on like how frequently it shows up
in the trees and you have one hot
encoded something that's gonna not be
very useful so something that's totally
mounted model agnostic like permutation
importance there's an implementation of
this and they explain like I'm by
package and for those who don't know
permutation important space so you take
your your data set and your fitted model
you use your holdout data set for this
so you can run it through the model look
at the predictions to calculate whatever
your score is r squared log loss what if
you're looking at and then one column at
a time you shuffle the data in that
column make your predictions again and
check how much worse your score has
gotten if you're intuitively if your
scores gotten a lot of worse it's a
veritable is quite important in
or for your model and so this and doing
that on the holdout set can give you a
really clear idea of like how you know
what features count for actual
performance on unseen data and so you
can get you know beyond what just the
model has over fit on something and
thinks this feature is amazing when it's
not so I think that's very valuable if
you want to know something about the
different effects of different groups
shop values are a good approach
it's go too far into them there's a
quite a good package and it's it's
actually integrated into all of the atop
great interesting libraries so it's
actually quite easy to use you could do
a whole session about it and I and I
won't but worth a look if you haven't
heard of it before
final final section so John strategy
this will be specifically about the big
the big three according boosting
packages yes so what what do they do in
one line extra boost it's really similar
to scikit-learn you basically have to
pre-process things and only feed in
numeric data so you use one of the
strategies we've talked about before
like GBM has categoría where split
strings rebuilding which explain a
little bit and cat boost has uses target
encoding and it does it in a way that's
really good and resistant to overfitting
problems we talked about before so it's
kind of in general specific to decision
trees why can one hot encoding be bad
and kind of in a nutshell you you end up
doing things like this where you're
building trees and you're splitting them
and you can only split one group at all
at a time you know you have a column for
1:01 column for group 0 and group 1 and
group 2 and you can only split one of
them off at a time and so if you're
gonna make some splits on groups it's
gonna require a huge amount of splits
levels in your trees and that's just
gonna be hard to cope with when you're
imposing any kind of constraints on your
tree is another way either way you
prevent trees from overfitting as you
limit the length or the length the depth
or the number of splits or the number of
different trees in the model and so if
you have a very hungry categorical
variable with 10000 columns that's
meeting up all your splits it's it's
gonna be hard to find some parameters
that work well for the category and for
the regular numeric they're variables
you have in the data set so that's kind
of the main main problem so like GBM
category aware of splits so which
basically means it can you know if you
have ten groups you can do a split with
five and five before splitting your
order group based on that target
reference here there's a cat smooth
parameter and a max cat to one hot so
below a certain value we'll just use one
hot encoding and then smooth things so
basically I've got a one minute warning
so I'm gonna wrap it up as quick as I
can
but basically you you take the group
save you have ten groups cat like GBM
will order them from some gradients I'm
Hessian basically big positive errors
too on the right too big negative errors
on the left and then it will look for a
split between those and what the smooth
cat parameter will do is take small
groups like eight here and shrink them
towards the center which will affect
where the splits found
and but you can directly you know as
opposed to one hunt encoding you can do
splits like this I had some assimilated
example which I'm going to skip through
in the interest of time showing how
increasing the cat smooth parameter
increased your your goodness-of-fit
final thing cat boost so it's just
target encoding and the way it does that
is you have you randomly shuffle your
data a few times and then you calculate
basically target encoded statistics so
in this case the mean mean of the
variable but you do it in a chronic tall
kind of way
so starting at the beginning your data
set you know nothing and then the values
in a fourth row will be based on all
previous instances of that example and
so on and so it kind of naturally adds a
little bit of noise to the variable in a
way that when the tree fits on it later
it's not going to over fit nearly as
badly and so this is just purely the
mean and I've been practiced there's a
bit of smoothing as well between the
global mean so the mean of all the Y I
have in this table is three point eight
and so it will start from there and then
I've as a house like through the data
set and things will know more and more
data will be of involved in a
calculation and then these things may
diverge more and more from from the
group mean and so that is quite
resistant to overfitting and I think
especially when you have a lot of very
high cardinality variables it works
quite well that wouldn't push me towards
cappers in those situations
final thoughts really quick there's no
approach that's always best that easy
but not always useful answer is just try
everything and test it often doing up
time to do that so son I hope there's a
bit of intuition but a road map for
different things you can try and when
you
want to try those and wise thanks very
much
that's all for me
and I'm happy to take questions yeah
who's gonna say so we have about three
minutes or a few minutes for questions
back let's pass the mic around as we're
a warning I'm a little bit deaf borange
and every way so please speak up as much
as you can
all of this approach is quite encoding
like in in Ellicott so you know like
what hasn't somebody tried to do in the
API itself say I've got a character
variable it's an audible cardinal
whatever the labeling is so you don't
have ugly one hot dog coding yeah
something more elegant it has something
to try that
so hey she didn't didn't quit
has somebody tried encoding all this
into the model saying that I've got a
variable which is categorical yeah its
properties called Arnold cotton ordinal
rather having one Hardware you expand
the number variables you embed it into
the definition of the variable it's more
embedded in the API so I've got a
variable so we say that variables
properties are its it's not on function
cardinal function whatever you like I
think so for
like GBM and and cappers and stuff they
it's part of the API you declare things
as as categorical or not at fitting time
every every other cycle or an estimator
is totally unaware of what just numbers
to it so you have to figure it out
before you before you feed it in some
people use for example they would use
like GBM as their training the module
and they would use XG boost as the final
iteration of the model what about the
categorical because the fact the
categorical feature functionality is
different so how would you you know if
you want to use SG boost
yeah what would you do about the
categorical variables because extra
boost has less so extra boost I think
you think about it like you were
scikit-learn like everything by the time
your data hits XG boost it has to be a
number and it will just interpret it as
numeric and you know split it order it
from low to high ends and split it so I
think if you if you're doing stacking if
you're trying different models then
using extra boost as a final one you
know assuming that your earlier models
they're their outputs are numbers then
that'll be that'll be totally fine if
you're using XG boosts earlier on and
you you still have some strings in your
data you're gonna have to do something
with them before putting them - to boost
your last question then ask to take all
the other ones offline please thanks
very much
so the target encoding I think is
finalized it's a lot like if you would
just for a linear model straight away
and that would be your result right but
when you do the I'm wondering about the
leap one out encoding when you're
looking at the unseen data because then
you don't have a target to modify your
mean value with yes so the most is I
think they'll leave one out
implementation I mentioned will just
you'll kind of have two different
processes for training data and test
data so the training data will have the
leave one out adjustment applied and
then while you're when you're fitting
the encoder it will also keep a list of
all the true group means and then when
you're using it on unseen data on there
you know if you're doing your validation
or your models in production it will use
the full actual group mean so leave one
out adjustment is just on that training
time and I think it intuitively we think
about it's just like it's making the
variable a little less good so that your
machine learning wall is not gonna just
jump on it and you know only fit on that
and ignore all of your other all the
other data in your dataset bit like what
yeah yeah yeah and it's kind of when
actually one thing people did before cap
boost sokaku says that way of I'm making
the variable worse by doing a kind of
running running total thing I explained
well it's something people used to do is
David targeting code and then just add
noise to it so that you're fitting your
model it's it doesn't look that powerful
and so making you know doing some target
encoding and then just adding some noise
to it I so just kind of very happy way
of regularization actually sometimes
works so I think at Bruce ways is better
but that's convinced what people used to
do before before I was available all
right thanks very much yeah we'll end it
there I suppose and thanks very much
Leona is a great talking
[Applause]